even though season 3 of tell tales
Walking Dead is still a ways out won't
be long until you can get your hands on
tell tales Michonne miniseries the first
of three episodes into deep will arrive
on PlayStation and Xbox consoles mac and
pc on februari 23rd the ios and android
version will launch on the 25th into
deep follows the story of me shown the
sword wielding character from the show
and comics as she joins Pete and his
crew to find supplies and survivors
along the coast the miniseries will
provide some backstory on her absence
from issues 126 to 139 of Robert
Kirkman's comic book series tell tale
set in the description when a desperate
signal for help draws them to a scene of
horrific massacre is shown in the crew
are led further to the floating
survivors colony of Monroe which may
just be harboring the person responsible
for the carnage the following episode is
supposed to arrive in March and the
final one is scheduled to land in April
you can purchase a season pass for
fifteen dollars when the first episode
becomes available telltale will release
the first five minutes of gameplay on
their YouTube channel this weekend so be
on the lookout for that and for more
details on all the tell-tale and walking
dead games you're already in the right
place